how long has it been since I've done one
of these videos huh yeah spin a minute
[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube Oh how did
how does that feel
how you doing cuz you know your boy
doesn't do these comedy videos that
often because you know my channels dead
Korona came in blessed my channel even
before the virus came out
seriously YouTube hates me but [ __ ] the
views and the money I'm just doing this
for you to give y'all a little giggle
and a little insight now everyone in the
world unless you're living under a rock
knows exactly what the coronavirus is by
now
Cobin 19 and if you don't know how
serious the situation is and how
important it is for you guys to practice
social distancing you're probably one of
these [ __ ] whatever happens
happen it's really messing up with my
spring break
what is there to do here other than go
to the bars or the beach they're closing
all of it it's really messy I think
they're blowing it way out of proportion
I think it's doing way too much going
this bad we need a refund
God just just give them the Rona if
anybody just give them no problem no
when you look at somebody and you say
they look like hot trash this is it
that's it I can't believe how much
garbage is in the ocean and I'm not
talking about soda cans I'm talking
about these inbred koban spreading dump
trucks Jesus has given up on us y'all
[ __ ] it's you it's you like
look at this trash bag we're just trying
to roll with the boy we're just living
for the moment we're just going for
we're just gonna do what happens when it
happens when stuff closes we're gonna do
when it closes but uh besides that
weirdest are living for the moment what
moment are you talking about for a fact
you are the last person that should be
talking about living your best life with
that abusive haircut of yours mom oh you
look like you watch anime porn all day
and get rejected by Asian women as a
hobby explain to me what the redness
around your mouth is my guy what you had
a vacuum on your mouth all day but did
you think having a vacuum on your face
was the closest thing that you'll get to
sucking someone else's face huh this is
definitively people who are narcissistic
selfish and arrogant for no [ __ ]
reason because for some reason a
national threat such as a virus is not a
big deal because it won't kill them so
[ __ ] everybody else I mean it sucks but
we're gonna make the best of it we enjoy
myself it sucks and I'm from the water
so this really sucks however we're gonna
enjoy ourselves we have a day parties
outing it's my birthday stamp agent
named Turner went in the butt [ __ ]
history has this ever happened your
lifetime but you wouldn't take this [ __ ]
seriously what it's your birthday [ __ ]
Oh Korona didn't know it was your
birthday
Oh Rona sorry near Rona Rona bad your
birthday you dumb [ __ ] I praise your
last Joe leopard-print straw hat looking
like a discount Liz oh I don't know why
you wearing leopard-print
anything with your slow lookin as you
ain't catchin [ __ ] but their owner it's
st. Patrick's Day you ain't Irish ho
just cuz you eat a lot of Lucky Charms
[ __ ] don't make you Irish don't even
get me started on this [ __ ]
right here at the end of the day I'm not
gonna want to stop me from partying you
know I've been waiting we
wait for Miami Spring Break for a while
about two months of how to strip playing
to three months oh we're not even having
a good time
whatever happens have a plan this for
two months oh well your parents didn't
plan to use any birth control because
they had your dumbass you [ __ ]
mistake the hell with children to hell
with my parents that elderly [ __ ] all of
them because I'm not gonna die for me
well it's not just about you you virus
spreading rosy cheek [ __ ] boy how are
people so dumb in this nation of ours we
have free education up until the point
that you are 18 which is long enough for
you guys to learn that you have a
[ __ ] brain the public education
system has failed you and not only that
[ __ ] we have Google there's
knowledge at your fingertips explain
this to me
inbred mother but you have any idea what
we look like to other nations because of
people like you the French are laughing
at us once more steadfast you'll be the
mill I can it happens I don't watch that
our face it's Samia mati I'm at the
pasta okay I can't do the time man we
need a refund
there's Marth ain't that serious cereal
it's more serious things out there like
hunger and poverty we need to address
them this is the problem people these
are the type of arguments that dumb
selfish people make because he's making
a comparison to poverty and hunger or
what else even though that has nothing
to do with the situation at hand what
the [ __ ] are you talking about guy just
because poverty and hunger is a big
issue my friends it doesn't change the
severity of the situation right now what
the [ __ ] does that have to do with the
coronavirus this is an example of how a
dumb person creates an argument and the
hardest part about having a conversation
or even arguing with a dumb person is
just based on the fact that they're
[ __ ] dumb you can explain to this guy
that yo those issues have nothing to do
with this and it doesn't change the
severity of this situation he's so
[ __ ] dumb he wouldn't even understand
it and he'd probably think that you're
stupid I don't know who this guy is
trying to give a life advice to with
that Japanese [ __ ] hair on your chin
[ __ ] I should pixelate your whole face
this is what we're dealing with people
here's my advice stay away from social
gatherings do not take this lightly yes
if even if you get the corona virus you
will most likely survive if you're young
and healthy and you don't have any
respiratory issues as previously stated
by
CDC however the issue is is that you
guys are spreading this disease a lot
faster and there are a lot more people
that can be affected and stay away from
large crowds my god I just natural
selection God just take them away just
take them on what Sanaa me cuz yeah well
since I'm in quarantine guys I might
make a lot more of these videos and
remember to check out the podcast every
Thursday and Sunday because who knows
how long I'm gonna have two podcasts a
week I don't know remember genius brain
Thursday in Sundays and who knows I'll
be putting out more of these videos
because well I got us to cope